please welcome the president of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences screenwriter director and Oscar
winner Frank Pearson
Bienvenue and willkommen
bienvenida ten Venuto dobro Coronado PI
jolivet i knew i was going to be able to
do this show um Ocalan was harlan on ye
and caribou knee and welcome to our 74th
annual celebration of the movies in
america the early silence movies were
made for an audience of immigrants who
spoke no english and had no common
language the movie makers soon learned
to turn their crude fantasies into a
unit into an art form
a universal language that brought
hundreds of millions of people together
at the movies to share the same laughter
the same thrills and dreams the film
community has always depended upon the
free creativity of its artists free at
least until the budget comes in and the
meeting start and it is that freedom of
expression that we celebrate tonight as
we honor the achievements of this year's
nominees and it is that freedom that we
defend against enemies both without and
within as president of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences it is
my pleasure to welcome you from all
nations of the world to the movies in
our magnificent new theater here on the
Boulevard of Dreams where it all began
enjoy the show and thank you
for his performance in Ally Will Smith
every year presenters come out here and
try to explain what some of the more
technical categories mean to the average
movie-going audience this year we
thought we'd let a group of the world's
best known screenwriters explain them
for us for film editing we turn to a
previous Oscar nominee David Mamet to
give us his personal viewpoint that
ought to keep the censors alert for a
few minutes at least here's what mr.
Mamet had to say the humbling truth is
that a film is made in the editing room
the most magnificent performances and
the best intentions mean nothing if they
don't cut the film goes by at 24 frames
per second and however lovely it is
however thoughtful it is however deeply
felt all the audience cares about is
what happens next the director the actor
the designer the writer can and do
become sidetracked confused indeed even
inspired into serving two masters the
story and themselves the editor serves
only the story as such they are the best
friend of the audience and time and
again the salvation of the filmmaker the
nominees for best film editing are
Mike Hill and Dan Handley for a
beautiful mind Pietro Scalia for Black
Hawk Down John Gilbert for the Lord of
the Rings the Fellowship of the Ring
Jody Dorn
for memento Jill bill [ __ ] for Moulin
Rouge the Oscar goes to Pietro Scalia
for Black Hawk Down
this is the fourth Academy of
Oscar for Australia they connected his
fur
ninety-two for Oliver Stone's JFK
is unbelievable Thank You members of the
Academy for honoring Black Hawk Down and
my fellow editors and nominees tonight
this is one of the rare moments where we
as editors get to share a corner of the
limelight with the stars and editors and
directors I'm sorry and it feels great
editors are like alchemists we play with
magic and we are privileged to witness
small miracles of creation when we
combine the talents and contributions
from everyone involved in the process of
making movies I wouldn't be standing up
here if it weren't for the generosity
and trust of Ridley Scott I would like
to share this award with my crew and
everyone that has contributed success of
Black Hawk Down special thanks to the
Moroccan people of rabat & salé a for
their hard work and hospitality Maya
Julian and Theresa you blessed my life I
love you and thank you very much Viva
l'Italia
to